[Music]  how's this sound if you break something  I can fix it I have a school for young  people who are like Eugene we could be  your new family if you like go Qureshi  where is she  she should be dead whatever happened up  there made her stronger she's changing  it what I'm scared I'm gonna lose  control bad things happen to people I'm  not giving up on Yugi this is what  family does we take care of each other  so that power destroyed everything it  ever came into contact with until you  what they don't understand they fear  and what they fear we seek to destroy  are you scared little girl who answers  to a man in a chair are you the most  powerful creature on the planet  this is your fault Charles tell me how  we fix this trough tell me what to do  don't know what to do  girl dies she still Jean which is still  helpful sometimes you want to believe  people are something that they are not  whether time you realize who they are  it's too late  she's coming  [Music]